nouveaux rebondissements dans la sphère
delphine jubile art de dossiers qui qui
bouleverse les français alors que depuis
juin cédait jubilaire son ancien
compagnon est en détention provisoire
étant considéré comme le suspect numéro
un dans la disparition de son ex femme
se dresse jubile art mais s'il a fait
quelque chose qui le disait aujourd'hui
une source proche du dossier affirme que
l'actuelle compagne de cédric jubilaire
aurait été interpellé ce matin vers 8
heures alors est ce que ça signifie que
les enquêteurs ont de nouveaux éléments
que cherchaient-ils vraiment elle aurait
été placé en garde à vue pour recel de
cadavres les enquêteurs cherchent à
savoir si elle aurait eu un rôle ou non
ces disparitions les enquêteurs peuvent
la suspectaient de savoir où se trouve
le corps d delphine jubilaire alors
après 20 ans dans quatre jours pour
jours la police hors est elle sur le
point de trouver ce qui s'est passé
cette fameuse nuit du 15 décembre 2020
ce soit nous faisons de nouvelles
révélations en plateau
quelle affaire la sphère jubilent à rien
on a la chance d'avoir sébastien devaud
chef de la fois aux nouveaux détectives
je suis fan du nouveau détective je vous
dise à cause du nouveau détective que
j'ai failli me retrouver à new york sous
les verrous pour acheter tous les
nouveaux détectives je suis arrivé à new
york et les gens m'ont dit
merci donc sébastien c'est grâce à vous
que j'ai passé quelques jours en prison
c'est à lajunie
alors vous connaissez tous par coeur et
vous avez vous avez aussi et vous avez
aussi interroger la femme arrêtée ce
matin recel de cadavres qu'est ce que ça
veut dire recel de cadavres le recel de
cadavre grosso modo
on soupçonne séverine donc la compagne
de cédric jubile art d'avoir caché
dissimulé ou en tout cas d'avoir aidé à
dissimuler ou cacher le bar de galles
finit donc il aurait eu une complice en
fait c'est ça l'histoire exactement
alors comment cédric y at il rencontré
cette femme parce qu'on en vient de moi
on savait pas que cette histoire ils
sont rencontrés quand il était très très
jeune il avait droit à 18 ans tous les
deux d'accord c'était une fête il y
avait beaucoup de monde
on buvait un petit coup comme quand on a
17 18 ans et en fait c'est comme ça
qu'une belle histoire d'amour a commencé
une très belle histoire d'amour ils se
sont fréquentés ils sont devenus
complètement amoureux il ya cette
demande de mariage plusieurs années plus
tard absolument incroyable où il ya ce
gâteau d'anniversaire ou pas le pardon
de mariage où il écrit dessus veux tu
m'épouser en plein restaurant voilà
c'est une très belle histoire d'amour
départ car je vis là c'est ça alors et
vous l'avez interrogé pour votre journal
là cette femme qui est qui est là qui
était la maîtresse de
juby de cédric beal à quai c'est quoi sa
personnalité c'est une femme qui
achètent peu qui âgé de 44 ans encore
c'est une femme qui a beaucoup de
caractère c'est assez commun de temps
qu'ils étaient ensemble en fait c'est
quoi exactement quand est-ce qu'ils sont
rencontrés ils se connaissent très très
jeune enfin relativement jeunes en tout
cas on parle parfois de d'amis d'enfance
mais apparemment ça serait en avril 2021
se seraient rencontrés séverine qui
participaient à des battues à trouver un
jour un pull pensant que le pull
appartenait à delphine il a elle a
apporté à cédric qui lui a dit c'est
gentil mais c'est pas le pull de
delphine jeu c'est comme ça que leur
histoire a commencé enfin aurait
commencé parce que ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes quant même
les enquêteurs n'ont toujours pas
retrouvé le cadavre de delphine
duvillard c'est le problème aujourd'hui
ce qu'il ya encore un espoir ou bien
il ya forcément un espoir à partir du
moment où il ya une mise en examen pour
recel de cadavres c'est que les
enquêteurs en tout cas pense qu'il ya un
espoir d'accord mais le problème c'est
qu'en l'état comme le dit l'adage pas de
corps pas de crime cette fois tout le
monde sait ça vous tracez s'amener saada
veut rien et voilà il cédric ne lâche
rien alors oui oui alors en fait ils ont
entendu cette personne et six autres
personnes dans l'entourage de cédric
jubila ça fait presque un an qu'elle a
disparu et j'espère que les langues vont
se délier donc ils ont pris des détenus
qui sont avec cédric jubila les entrées
cette jeune femme ils ont pris d'autres
personnes et ils veulent en savoir plus
ils pensent que en étirant la garde à
vue elle va parler parce qu'elle est un
peu complexe quand même pendant l'
enquête à la cité d'autres pistes a dit
vous faites fausse route voudriez
m'écouter donc c'est une personne un peu
je dirais bizarre et il a envie qu'elle
éclaircisse plein de points avec les
enquêteurs alors en début de semaine
déjà une grosse information qui tombait
sur cédric jubilent à la petite soeur de
cédric jibidar était sur écoute
téléphonique pour les besoins d'une
enquête et une conversation entre elle
et son frère a été capté par les
enquêteurs alors qu'elle était au
téléphone avec son petit ami la jeune
femme avait oublié de raccrocher et sur
ces écoutes on entend cédric jubile art
conseiller sa soeur sur les moyens de se
défendre lycée au détour de cette
conversation il s'est vanté d'avoir
commis le crime parfait on a un extrait
regarder une conversation saisi par une
écoute téléphonique
le 16 mai dernier cédric jubile art
explique à sa demi soeur de 16 ans
comment se défendre au lycée il lui dit
notamment enola de toi moi je suis le
meurtrier est parfait pour l'instant
n'oublie pas que j'ai commis le crime
parfait si tu as besoin demande moi un
mois plus tard le 15 juin l'adolescente
est interrogé par les gendarmes sur
cette conversation elle dit qu'elle n'en
a pas le souvenir et que c'était dit sur
le ton de la rigolade cinq mois après la
disparition de delphine jubile art avoir
beaucoup du nord cette affaire
c'est ça c'est incroyable parce que
c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de haut niveau
c'était sur le ton de la rigolade au
sénat ça correspond qu'aux règles mais
complètement au caractère de 7,2 sur
youtube il est d'accord c'est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement provocateur n'a pas hésité
à dire je suis l'homme le plus connu de
cagnac-les-mines d'accord après moi
c'est en fait c'était une bouilloire qui
pour lui était importante bien sûr en
tout cas il il s'en vanter ça c'est une
certitude c'est oui gilles on peut tout
retourné dans cette affaire ses avocats
disent mais regardez cédric et la jeune
fille de 16 ans disent que c'est de la
rigolade de la provocation et vous
pensez que s'il avait commis le crime
parfait et se vanterait comme ça donc
ses avocats lui continue de dire pas
d'aveux pas de preuve pas de cadavre
mettez le en liberté pour moment tout
est rouge arrive les soupçons se portent
de plus en plus sur cédric jubile un oui
il ressort la vigile c'est ce qui
ressort l'actuel manque alors il n'y a
pas de nouveaux éléments par ailleurs
c'est la piste privilégiée vraiment
c'est la piste privilégiée parce que
tout simplement les enquêteurs en fait
ils fonctionnent par soustraction ils
ont fermé les pistes la disparition
volontaire le suicide rien de coulé on
l'a quand même d'une femme qui a peur du
noir qui part en pleine nuit sans ses
lunettes
voilà c'est étonnant il n'y a pas de
preuves matérielles objectifs des
enquêteurs ils sont diverses dès qu'il
est coupable ah oui d'ailleurs on le
voit avec 7,7
garde à vue ça montre que c'est vraiment
la piste privilégiée pour eux c'est sûr
ils cherchent une excuse voilà ils
négligent aucune piste d'accord c'est
clair mais en tout cas voilà cette garde
à vue montre qu'il est toujours dans
l'oeil de 6 tonnes malgré les pare feux
qui sont allumés par les avocats de la
défense avec le fameux amendement touba
sable alors c'est moi l'horizon n'est
pas de la finale la piste de l'amant de
delphine gaieté ouverte va jamais jamais
ouverte en fait pourquoi ils creusent
pas un peu cette piste alors à ils ont
creusé adopte donc complètement creusé
et jusqu'à dorin et l'or elle avait un
amant et 300 sur fils apparemment à la
boxe et donc est donc là au niveau de
cette piste il ya rien de ils ont tous
fui des ils ont vérifié ils ont vérifié
et son alibi en fait comme ça tient donc
il y avait aucune raison de m'inquiéter
plus donc il est élu il est hors de
cause a priori leur évidemment dans
cette affaire comme l'a dit gilles tout
peut arriver mais je vois là à l'heure
où je vous parle il n'est absolument
rien contre l'amendement tôt dans le
truc con c'est la question qu'on se pose
tous insérés qu'on a tous suivi cette
affaire incroyable on se dit au bout
d'un an c'est vrai que comment ça se
fait qu'on ait autant d'incertitudes
tout simplement comme je met à l'heure
parce que vous n'avez pas de corps ouais
et à partir et quand vous n'avez pas de
corps c'est très compliqué vous n'avez
pas d'aveu de la part de cédric on ne
sait pas grand chose alors ils quelques
éléments qui est si ya pas de corps ils
peuvent le maintenir en détention bien
sûr mais plus on va penser mais c'est
bien
sûr deux procès aux assises où il n'y
avait pas de corps ils ont dû y avait
des éléments qui étaient tellement
importants mais que cela justifier une
mise en examen puis un procès ils ont
cherché partout du sang dans la maison
il n'y a jamais eu de cesse jamais de
même sur la couette qui était avec cette
chose incroyable il appelle la police à
3 heures du matin quand il dit que sa
femme est apparue la première chose qui
fait après appelé la police c'est de
faire tourner une machine avec les
grands métiers at il jouit mais vous
avez tout à fait raison mais cette
couette était vérifiée aucune trace de
sang les seules roues il entre les deux
taux à 3 heures du matin à mais
complètement c'est ça c'est très curieux
sa chance il n'était pas connu pour être
quelqu'un extrêmement dense
mais ils ont fait leur mission celle h
et la maîtresse chez séverine ils ont
une perquisition ce matin vous verriez
apparemment et gendarmes seraient
repartis avec des sacs donc on peut se
demander ce qu'il ya dans ces sacs mais
d'ajuster la course avait déjà il était
déjà rentré dans le domicile de séverine
en juin dernier à l'époque où cédric
avait été interpellé et là c'était
simplement une audition libre d'accor
gilles en fait elle a connu cédric bien
après en avril bien après la disparition
mais il pense vraiment qu'elle sait
quelque chose cédric par l'e book au
téléphone beaucoup avec elle il avait
des conversations il pense qu'elle va
finir par dire oui je sais où il m'a
avoué que parce qu'elle a des
déclarations contradictoires et sinon
pour répondre à votre question c'est
vrai que les avocats de cédric jubilaire
ils disent mais de la remise en liberté
de remise en liberté vous n'avez rien
c'est en clôture ont toutes les autres
pistes et là avec cette action de 6
personnes entendues plus elles qu'elles
veulent être irréprochable et ils
veulent dire voyez on a tout essayé il
n'y a rien d'autre que lui donc c'est
lui voilà la stratégie des gendarmes le
ton qu'elle n'est aujourd'hui pas bon je
sais que l'histoire me passionne c'est
que c'est effectivement il pourrait être
gardé en prison pour qu'il ait un procès
mais là il va être lâché par ce cas rien
contre lui notamment même les
témoignages un étranger
sont trop petits ne sont pas encore
considérés comme des témoignages assez
important pour le moment parce que dans
deux cas les avocats c'est pour le
moment ils ne pourront pas le garder
comme ça avec ce qu'ils ont dans le
dossier ce que disent escaliers les
avocats de la défense ont par les
avocats de la défense qui font la
procédure entendons nous bien il ya
d'autres éléments que les témoignages
des enfants dans le dossier il ya par
exemple leur exemple quoi le contexte de
disparition que je vous ai cité les
arrangements aussi de cédric avec la
vérité avec la vérité parfois il faut le
dire malheureusement au début il déclare
ne pas être au courant d'un amant pour
finalement laisser là beaucoup menti
dans ce dossier cédric c'est quoi les
morceaux qu'il a fait dans nos
téléspectateurs
alors par exemple donc il parle d'une
séparation en douceur absolument pas
mais j'ai même été question d'une
séparation en douceur elle était très
très très difficile delphine parler
d'une vie de bidochon par le soir j'ai
rien contre les bidochon les villages on
peut voir ce que ça peut vouloir dire
c'était une séparation qui se passait
très mal
c'est alors il ya cette histoire des gr
3 heures du matin comment il justifie sa
lettre où elle justifie sa la couette
qu'il a fait ils le justifient ils
justifient pas vraiment simplement qu'il
a lancé une machine
n'aura pas disparu à 3 heures du matin
ils ont su le matching voilà qui s'est
dit aussi que la série d'autres
soumettent à bernard
thibault n'importe qui quelqu'un
disparaît à 3 heures du matin tu appelle
tes amies rappelle mes potes tu appelles
la famille tu attends un petit peu tu
n'appelles pas 3h du matin la police
quand la compagne de kits à 3 heures du
matin rien que ça approuvée déjà par
l'appel c'est vrai qu'il appelait la
première danse n ya plus qu il ya eu un
épisode similaire au mois d'août où
delphine avait dit avait disparu pendant
je crois une nuit en fait elle était
partie regarder les étoiles il s'en est
pas du tout inquiète et ne l'avait pas
appelé la police à corps les proches il
n'a appelé personne là cédric appelle
tout de suite j'ai c'est que sa ferme a
dit ce père si c'est lui le coupable
c'est peut-être ça qui le donne il est
peut-être ce jour là quant à lui
peut-être soit ce type est un génie
pardon et de mauvais sens du terme soit
7 soit soient sauves a retrouvé le corps
mais je moi je pense qu'on essaie la
future affaire grégory je crois qu'on va
avoir quelque chose qui va être
incroyable et compte je pense vraiment
gilles verdez et puis il ya quelque
chose d'incroyable c'est que quand tout
le monde cherchait sa femme quand tout
le monde cherchait des fines et bien lui
il ne cherchait pas non mesdames
écrivent ça dans les battues il est
multiple battu caen s'ils étaient
absents ou selon les enquêteurs comme
s'il savait que ça servait à rien de
chercher donc sa vraie ma maison il peut
dire il peut dire qu'ils étaient sidérés
de retourner son attitude voilà quand
même sidéré tout le monde et puis aussi
il ya quelque chose qui a vraiment gêné
c'est quand il a connu cette nouvelle
compagne donc en avril lors d'une battue
vous le disiez il a fait un post sur les
réseaux sociaux et tout le monde toute
sa famille ses proches des proches de
delphine on dit quelques mois après la
disparition il se remet déjà avec
quelqu'un et ça ça a été pris comme il
ne tient pas vraiment à des fûts voilà
séverine qui au départ d'ailleurs nié la
la c'est ça la maîtrise mais voilà le
nier être en couple avec lui rit elle
elle a eu beaucoup de versions qui ont
changé dans la presse pas que parce
qu'ils se sont connus lors d'une battue
friable c'est quoi l'histoire c'est
comme ça il fouilla ensemble et
effectivement elle a trouvé un élément
elle est arrivée ils se connaissaient de
vue dialogue que c'était un peu amis il
habitait à côté donc elle est arrivée
elle a dit j'ai peut-être trouvé quelque
chose d'essentiel
la rencontre a eu lieu à ce moment là
ils sont restés en contact et ils sont
devenus amants avril ils ont une
aventure ils connaissent et cédric ouest
de séverine sefouhi communiquent par
lettre puisqu'il n'a pas le droit de
recevoir des appels elle lui écrit des
lettres il lit en prison l'aide qui sont
lus par les magistrats avant lui arriver
est ce que vous pensez qu'il va avoir un
dénouement 7 a fait on pensait comme
matthieu delormeau que ça être une
affaire qui sera jamais revenir était
déjà un mec exercé au potentiel
intellectuel souvent ces gens là sont
des fous mais qui sont extrêmement
intelligent il est tombé à cause de sa
femme à la fin mai mais lui tomba tempo
pour quelqu'un d'autre aussi mais il est
très intelligent jeu pour répondre à
votre question je pense que ça prendra
du temps non on est au début il faut
aussi dire que séverine c'est le soutien
le soutien avec un l majuscule de cédric
jubilaire même la propre mère de cédric
jubila à douter un moment donné de son
fils elles n'ont jamais ce qu'elle aime
toujours pensé que cédric était innocent
chacun imagine le elle le soutient parce
que j'étais dans l'orthographe là
alors c'est vous cl tu penses ça est
révolu moi je pense que oui je pense que
là un coup d'épée dans l'eau si là ça
fait un an date symbolique presque un an
y prennent six personnes elle je pense
qu'ils ont l'intuition que quelqu'un va
parler je pense que ça risque d'évoluer
dans les prochaines heures franchement
avec des éléments tangibles